jean voyelles jean-gabriel guenassia
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors tout d'abord quel
est votre regard sur les débuts de
l'application stop qu'ovide ils sont
plus que l'implication et été
téléchargée assez massivement ce conduit
là c'est un succès qui a pas de refus le
lan / il faut s'assurer que le nombre de
téléchargements va être suffisant pour
pouvoir contribuer à la limitation de la
de la pandémie et ça c'est le premier
point de l'efficacité par la ville on
sait que c'est un outil parmi d'autres
outils que ça n'est pas l'application
tout seul c'est l'application et vitesse
depuis l'application et tout un tas
d'autres mesures qui vont être
extrêmement important pour le futur
ensuite il ya une deuxième question qui
est important pour nous en france c'est
que l'application stock provident
même si elles tracent les contacts ne
trace pas les années du plus exactement
que d'une part donc les gens qui la
télécharge piste de rester anonyme que
leur nom ne soit pas mentionné qu'on ne
dissimulent pas leur état de santé ni
les contacts des gens avec qui ils ont
échangé et puis deuxièmement que ce soit
volontaire c'est à dire que l'on puisse
une fois qu'on l'a téléchargé l'activer
et la désactiver homme qui est une alité
aucune et deux au dos au point de vue il
semble que ça donne plutôt satisfaction
donc ambitions on croit savoir que plus
tard mais les premiers signes ont l'air
plutôt en croyant et de parfums dernier
point il fallait que techniquement ça
puisse s'installer sans difficulté sur
les différents téléphones portables et
là encore bon il semblerait que les
choses se passent plutôt bien donc pour
l'instant on est sûr c'est quelque chose
d'assez positif mais mobilisation ce
qu'on pense ainsi que pour que ce soit
vraiment utile
il faut que les un pourcentage important
de la population française qui puisse
télécharger le logiciel pour l'instant
on est certainement croire j'ai pas les
chiffres exacts mais c'est quand même
plusieurs centaines
de milliers en tout cas dès les premiers
jours laisse entendre que c'est un
avantage non négligeable vous voyez donc
comme on peut imaginer que les gens qui
la téléchargent sont un peu dans le dans
le même milieu socio puisqu'il faut qu'
il ya des deux côtés et un contact la
explications sont à télécharger donc ce
soit efficace
on peut penser quand même que ça va
l'être mais surtout ça je crois que ce
sera très intéressant dans le futur même
d'essayer de d'avoir une idée précise de
cela alors on sait que c'est à peu près
vide et a suscité beaucoup de débats
autour de nos libertés qu'on est il
vraiment répond elle aux critères le
l'application stockée ville est
construite à partir d'un protocole qui a
été conçu par les ria qui est un
institut de recherche en informatique et
aussi par le fraudeur qui est indiquée
en égalant le protocole s'appelait
robert c'est un sigle qui désigne je ne
sois plus exactement mais ça veut dire
que ces protocoles de transmission qui
répond juste et qui part d'un certain
nombre d'axés que les noms ne doivent
pas être connues donc ils sont encodées
qui sont cryptés avec des techniques
extrêmement efficace deuxième chose le
fait qu' on ne possède pas on ne
contient pas sa forme plus ou moins de
stock pas sur le téléphone portable
l'ensemble des contacts qui sont
envoyées à un ordinateur central et cet
ordinateur central donc va si une
personne se déclare comme étant malade
directement envoyé des messages aux
personnes contacts que vous avez eue et
à ce moment là donc celle ci recevront
une suggestion leur dira voilà vous avez
été en contact avec quelqu'un qui s'est
révélé être contagieux et à ce moment là
vous allez vous devriez sans le bailleur
les contraintes
vous devriez faire un test et
éventuellement si vous présentez des
symptômes aller voir un médecin du point
de vue là il ya quand même beaucoup de
cas
anting qui sont prises et la présence de
la cnil pour vérifier l'application va
rester anonyme tu croyais est tout à
fait essentiel pour of la préservation
des libertés bien sûr rien n'est jamais
en question mais très rapidement s'il
vous plaît à l'heure on sait que
certains experts informatiques et juris
craignent tout de même que ce soit une
porte d'entrée dans une société de
surveillance est ce que vous partagez
cette crainte
alors moi je ne partage pas du tout
cette gran je pense que eux les d'abord
une mesure de solidarité le fait
d'installer nous sommes coville sur son
téléphone ça témoigne de la volonté de
contribuer à limiter la pandémie c'est
un peu comme la vaccination est la
vaccination s'injecte la maladie ce pas
pour ça qu'on va être malade et on le
fait non seulement pour soi mais on le
fait pour les autres je crois qu'il en
va exactement de même de l'application
stankovic mais attention pour que ça ne
soit pas effectivement la porte ouverte
hier une société de surveillance
il faut qu'il y ait une surveillance de
l'application stable covin et ses
sources que ce que beaucoup de gens font
et je crois qu'il faut être attentif
plus que jamais mais que en étant
attentif en étant sur nos gardes et bien
on peut limiter toutes les dérives qui
sont envisagées avec les dérives que
certains craignent donc on a raison de
craindre mais en même temps il ya quand
même des outils des outils législatifs
des outils techniques pour empêcher que
nous soyons ici d'une surveillance
jean-gabriel ganascia merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
informaticiens philosophe directeur du
comité d'éthique du cnrs